i come from a startup called mesosphere
it works with and around apache missiles
so
hence how many have heard about missiles
before
cool how many have tried missiles
great um
so i'm nicholas and i'm
also a committer in the apache project
because methods is a top tier
apache project which is great
so
i can't promise to to answer all
questions that you might have on
missiles but
i can definitely point you the right
direction
so let's start with a small agenda i did
that
um one missiles
three profit this was a
reference to south park i don't know if
you've seen the
underpants stealing gnomes and their
um profit plan so uh but no
uh hopefully this talk will be
mutually beneficial because we are all
about having a community around apache
mesos
because it's really a result of that
community and hopefully this will be a
gentle
quick introduction to uh to what messes
is
and we end up using the language that
you like
i have to say that i'm a separate class
programmer and the first
project i did was language bindings and
messing with seago
and enabling that on misos so if you see
any
non-idiomatic go please shoot me an
email or
report on github that would be too
so let's jump right into it
so what is the problem today with
data center management
it might be that the most common
practice to run your services
and run your apps is to
delegate that to vms in the sense that
either you have your own bare metal
machines that you cut in pieces with vms
or you get that um hosted somewhere
um
while that might not necessarily be a
problem we think there's definitely an
opportunity to do better imagine if your
browser was like this
whenever you open up an application you
had to pick what cpu it was running on
and if another application was running
on that it would fail
this is kind of how we see the static
partitioning of a data center
looking like you've seen in operating
systems
for decades really neat abstractions
like
virtual memory or scheduling multiple
processes on
a single cpu so why shouldn't we be able
to do the same thing for
a cluster
not only because it's easier for a
programmer not dealing with
physical memory banks and that kind of
stuff but also to
make global and more efficient decisions
about
let's say page replacement policies and
that kind of stuff
so if we look at the alternative
which we call dynamic resource sharing
we could have a 16 ohm cluster cluster
here
where the majority of the nodes are
running hadoop
some of them are running web services
servers
and when the workload changes like say
throughout the day
and you have more web servers that needs
to be dealt with
um you should be able to
scale that automatically
so yeah recap if um you have different
kind of services they have different
kind of workloads
and there's no reason that they are not
sharing resources
so mesos is all about
resource sharing and resource isolation
it's a resource manager
because when you think about it you
don't really care about physical boxes
or virtual machines you care about
resources and mapping jobs and tasks
onto those resources and that is what
mesothel helps us do
let me just roll it so
how do you interact with messers mesos
is could be compared to an operating
systems kernel
you rarely interact with it directly you
interact with things that runs on top of
it
it could be chronos which is a framework
for permissives which are launched back
batch jobs on scheduled times
so it's almost like cron for your data
center
we have marathon which takes care of
high availability of long living or long
running services
so it's almost like an initiate for your
data center
we have different analytics because mrs
was a part of the amp
stack from from berkeley for spark
storm hadoop running on missiles too
and we'll get into the nice business of
writing a small framework so that's
where
our framework um fits in
and why i'm here because now you can
write those frameworks and go
so let's get into some details this is a
small quote from douglas adams that i
like if you try to take
a cat apart to see how it works the
first thing you'll have is an unworking
cat
and uh i really like about computer
science and computer engineering that we
can tear
really um complicated pieces of software
apart without hurting anybody
so this is going from the very nice
budget
figures to some handwritten ones
so when you where you saw metals as a
layer before
it's actually a hierarchy so you have
multiple frameworks
that communicate with a master to not
have any single point of failure we have
standby masters that in coordinate
coordinated zookeeper and all slaves all
compute nodes in your cluster then
communicates
and agrees on launching and resources
with the master and just to introduce
the two last
terms on a single slave
an executor launches tasks the tasks
is the unit of execution in methods
so what we can do
is missiles master doesn't
do make any decisions about allocations
the framework does that
so opposed to let's say an operating
system kernel that would where you say
give me x number of bytes
then you get it messages work with an
offer model
that would be that the message master
offers the scheduler some resources
and the scheduler can then choose to
accept by running some tasks on them
or declining to wait for something
better coming up
so this should be illustrated here like
first off
you get resource offers you choose to
accept those
you launch task the business master
propagates that to the executor
margin task the executor is responsible
for letting the schedule know that
things went well
and this is another handwritten point um
because why do we talk about language
bindings at all
so right now you can use c plus you can
use all jvm languages
closure scala and python
to write frameworks in
and the simple fact is that mesos
internally
has a actor library that's called
lip process and it's simply to to make
go um enable to
communicate with the master which goes
through lip process which is a library
in itself
so go calls into c go which with a
bunch of stubs simple bus stops calls
intellect methods
that's all there is to it
and i want to show you a small demo
um are there any questions so far about
what um so i have a cluster running
i've cheated a bit we created
a tool that's called elastic methods
that helps you launch
message clusters so the only thing you
do is that you click
a cluster size you type in your awns
aws credentials and a public key in your
email
and then that will provision a cluster
of that given size
but i already have that running and i'm
already logged in
can you see this text okay
i hope so
so this is basically
the structure of the git repo for uh
from mesoscope
this is part of the protobuf
and this is the c code that
binds it or links it to mesos
but what you do
is that you write a scheduler um
there's an accenture being put together
one thing that's worth mentioning is
that um
message uses protobufs or protocol
buffers which is way to describe
messages
so you put those together
and you're and you register a driver
and basically let's say this is the
entry point where you you get
an offer from a master
and for each of those offers we create a
task
and we launch it
so achieve a bit so the etc that i'm
about to run i put that
into the file system already
so all these slave nodes can pull that
binary
and that is like your master no that
that's that's active
and if we look at the
the web ui for cluster you'll see i've
run it a couple of times
this one just finished and
has five tasks and if
all tasks should have run in a decent
decent way
yeah that's uh that's more or less what
i have
do you guys have any questions
yeah um
yeah um let me go back to
the slide
so on a term basis the master would
offer resources
to frameworks and um
you will get no other resources um
offered until
you make a decision whether or not to
accept a human resource or to decline it
a resource could look like there's a
there's a box that has two cpus
available and 32 gigs of ram
and you say that's enough to run my task
and actually i only need half of it
and then you launch in half of it
yeah but there are algorithms that
ensure spanish across
all all the frameworks so one framework
cannot
starve other frameworks for example the
master is not getting communication
with regards to what you actually mean
exactly so all the logic sits in a
scheduler
so that was that was the the kind of new
thing
was that you you did have big monolithic
resource schedulers before
like sloan um but
they became inherently complicated piece
of software to maintain
so here you put you push that decision
upwards
cool yeah
so within mesos
all communication is over http and
protobuf serialized over http
so it's simply the awkness of the
internal http server
that prevents you from from from doing
that but we are working towards that
you just serialize the protocol and you
ride it towards an http endpoint
so yeah we look at that then you
wouldn't need all the
seago nastiness that's in place right
now
did you have a last question um
um
there is definitely some work being done
in
clever ways to determine that
you